sarajevo has stayed comparatively quiet
this morning apart from the occasional
crack of a sniper's bullet
his name his face his work might not be
familiar
but john scofield was a journalist
houses were still burning this morning
as sarajevo woke up from a day and night
of bitter fighting
he was killed whilst covering the 1995
conflict in croatia for the bbc
he was just 29. john who was working for
radio fours the world tonight was
traveling with three colleagues when
they came under fire from croat
troops now 25 years after his death john
is remembered by those that worked with
him not only as a great reporter
but a good man the thing you remember
the most about john is
youth enthusiasm honesty
just a lovely person i remember john he
was a wonderful man
he always wanted to go he always wanted
to be there to witness the event
as it happened and these equalities
john's widow wanted to honor
susannah schofield founded a charity
that helps young
journalists by matching them with
mentors already established in the media
and when john died i was swamped by
letters all saying ah he was a rising
star he was going to be the next leading
journalist he knew
nothing of this he really didn't think
he was
rated by his peers he was constantly
looking over his shoulder it is and it
still is
a cutthroat industry it's highly
competitive and i
vowed then that no young journalist
should be in that position where at the
age of 29 not even 30
to die and not know there were i've been
a trust mentor for a year
to layla wright a journalist from
liverpool and although
i'm more comfortable being the one
asking the questions
are we ready when you are wrong today
it's her turn
so why did you want to become a mentor i
wanted to try and
help in some way to create a sort of
environment that i wished had existed
when i was starting out i
didn't know anyone in the industry i
didn't even know that you could really
ask for help of people who were already
in the industry
although it's you know getting more and
more diverse at that time it was
quite small and it was who you know
really that got you in
you know maybe 15 years later is that
still the impression you get
definitely it's so true what you said i
think it sometimes it seems like an echo
chamber like
you know the people like sometimes it
can be a really daunted industry you
know i'm a freelancer
in liverpool don't really know many you
know journalists and i think
it's so important to have a network and
have it a safe kind of space to say you
know what
maybe i'm struggling with this or like
some more advice just having a place
where you can go and chat
and i think that's why i wanted to kind
of become a mentee and that network
means opportunities for people who might
not otherwise have got a foot in the
door
it's such a vital scheme to get people
from different backgrounds into this
industry
if you think about this industry it's
still overwhelmingly people that have
private education or people that are of
a certain background
my dad was a plumber my mum's a
stay-at-home mum
i didn't know absolutely anyone and i
didn't really understand how it all
worked and having a mentor that
does and that can push you and that can
answer all of your really really silly
questions
is just priceless john schofield's life
was cut
tragically short but his legacy
lives on katarina overtopsies